let's jump and welcomed another stream
Coco what's happening everybody thanks
for joining us this week
I know there will be no Beth I'm just
saying that up top so if you ask about
our I'll tell you things about her
that'll make up because I don't know a
lot about Beth because we don't speak
but you won't be here this week we're
going to play some on oculus it's over
here we are going to play but then now
we're not going to it's not we're gonna
play a little game called little
nightmares which is great cuz I have a
lot of nightmares my waking life is a
little nightmare
ah and this game just came out so I
guess spoiler alert do I need to say
that anyway
um what's going on I love you too freak
good to see you
hey blasting zombies hey Andy mutts
what's up alright let's play how's
everybody doing this game rocks ooh I
like it mag no more your SR hey so a CCC
on so is son how do you say that I like
just that this feels very night Vale ish
welcome to night Vale you guys know that
what's up yo yo yo yo yo
I don't know Gobber stopper we're gonna
see
this is already creeping me out by the
way it's not even scary says May H we'll
see about that
hey thanks blasting zombies I guess we
won't paying you what's happening here
what is that thing
silica geisha so weird oh don't be a
naked old lady man naked ladies scare me
please don't be a naked old lady whoa
that was creepy uh all right looks like
I'm a kid and I'm in a suitcase what the
hell all right this game looks cool
look look at me creep so I creep ya guys
is just like a TLC video ooh I can pick
up and throw cans good stand underneath
the rain I can run jump all right hey
thanks a lot RJ son of a [ __ ] oh well
there's weird little things we'll have a
light
I'll light this lamp so I guess that's
like a save point right all right here
we go
I killed Conan No avoid the long arms
and stay quiet all right
it was such a pain to Google this game
it was called hunger oh this game used
to be called hunger so my vampire is
Jordan a real human being first of all
it's being bei and G not bean but yes
he's a real he's a real human being not
a real human being I'm this game be
called hunger where's the long arms I
don't know what the long arms are this
game almost looks like claymation which
is kind of cool hello lost in twitch
verse good to see you
I hate lights and games cuz it makes me
feel vulnerable so I'm gonna keep my
light off oh this is cool
whoa I'm some sort of giant ship what
about if this is just a sequel - uh -
honey I Shrunk the Kids is that possible
there's like is that a person
it's weird geisha thing a Maya geisha am
I supposed to be like a Geisha so this
is a sex thing why should i dim the
lights in the room watch out for slugs
I don't like slugs man didn't like that
room see I can do the lights thanks
Riley
make it nice and creepy here who is it
ashtray and a bucket I guess I'm just a
smaller
oh yeah look we're dim in the light too
scary oh yeah
you can even go dimmer if you want oh
yeah there we go all right how's that
kids nice and freaky well there's a
chair on the ceiling for no reason all
right you know how dad likes to watch
his 60 minutes in a chair on the ceiling
hello Kyra n'ver sack surprise Grim
Fandango sequel is this by the people
who make grim fandago who here's a guy
who hung himself yeah I probably gotta
get this chair move this chair
this game is very pretty so far but
something vini a car this game reminds
me of inside so sison that's why i'm
playing it is because i love inside and
somebody said this game was a lot like
inside ooh let's open this door now see
normally I would light a light here but
I'm very uh copper stopper dude are you
just gonna quote Rick and Morty the
entire stream because that shit's boring
however have an original thought in your
head oh very much a target oh this is
creepy
well open this and someone will kill me
ah
oh hey thanks Marshall good to see it
thanks for joining us someone hung
themselves I don't know maybe they
didn't make their car payments don't
hang yourself kids cuz you know why cuz
you [ __ ] your pants and nobody oh oh I
think I don't want that thing near me
right uh weird scheme gonna have weird
slugs man I [ __ ] hate slugs oh yeah
uh not a fan of slugs thank you
I like this little baby see no I do here
oh poor things there's gonna be fat guys
chasing me oh no oh I'm dead you say fat
guys chasing me and I get all crazy and
I kill myself shout-out Rockstar Coffee
kills my personal stream is just Erin
Blair twitch.tv slash Erin Blair I'm
almost done with alien isolation it's
only taken me [ __ ] five years to beat
that game so Oh
slugs so this game just like a
collection of my nightmares cuz so far I
need to have Taylor Swift's new song in
there it's gonna be a collection my
nightmares cuz that's terrible
where's your shoutout Vic so it's just
gonna be me shouting everybody out
nobody wants that
there we go made it across bunch of
slugs up there how do you rid of slug
he's got a fumigate or something put
salt around right oh space turtle fine
everyone gets a shout-out ah Mohammed
yes we're playing on ps4 today but I
plan everything are these weird little
dudes this cutter bike oh [ __ ] that's
not good
I don't hear anything I don't want to
light a thing ah [ __ ] yeah oh this games
awful this game is awful oh I hate this
game uh I hate can I burn the slugs oh
that's awful
yeah guys why do slugs exist
can we just kill all the slugs I hate to
be like a uh who the hell is that dude
or lady lady dude I'll last two clues
gamer I don't know I when does not last
you come out is it out already
that's out I gotta play that [ __ ] our
last one was fun but a little silly I
need things to be somewhat based on
reality you know it's gonna be a rat
chasing me in a couple minutes
oh brother oh this is I hate this I hate
this a lot by the way why am i barefoot
can I just get some shoes wrap something
around your feet I mean I'm gonna get a
splinter
oh it's one of these things alright the
other thing is having played inside I
kind of know all these tricks this is
like a really kind of freaky version
inside what is up with this through
these dudes man
never catch this guy
this is exactly it see a blue light run
towards the light bees music run towards
the light oh I like being exposed like
this the [ __ ] listen this is like
rapidly becoming a tool video we're
about two degrees away from a tool video
carpa genic no you're right I'm not
really worried about splinters I'm more
worried about pneumonia potato people
our last takes place in my state and I
was suspicious of religious people that
aren't in big towns fair enough there's
a little I'm guessing these are like
save points right so I want to keep
hitting them Ashwin gee I suck well
thank you for showing up and making that
comment I think it's a great wait great
use of your time oh there's the rat I
feel like I shouldn't touch that thing
right
Rinku person yeah black bullet everybody
does bro
I am worried that the yellowjacket is
probably smells pretty bad
this person was sleeping in it look
around by using our okay right all right
run through here I'd like to go through
here please
all right now we're in a creepy area I'm
guessing they're slugs somewhere oh this
is crazy
ah what's going on Oh black bullet but
you said you loved Conan first so now
that you say you love me I don't believe
it
please say Aye if I see that comment
okay I know what's happening here is
there a switch in here
it looks very waterproof well it did
coat doesn't waterproof but it's like a
miniskirt so it's not really helping my
bare legs a slight draft huh
well this children's play see I'm a
child why am i so much smaller
yeah there's handprints I will say there
is something to the fantastic being
creepy but I also think like Resident
Evil being a little more based I mean I
know I'm saying based in reality that's
a joke but like this is creepy but the
fact is like is it really gonna scare me
I don't know I'll tell you it's gonna
scare me I'll tell you it's gonna scare
you my terrible ability of video games
it's a nightmare I see no it's a little
nightmare go back to the switch alright
but that ball come from by the way
I mean it definitely feels like a
nightmare
guys who's what was everybody's last
nightmare in the chat I want to hear
everybody's last night Amir mine weirdly
was stuff keeps like zooming in isn't
that weird like you'll start out in
space and little zoom in it'll keep
zooming into Earth and it zooms into a
person that it zooms into like their
cells then it zooms into like I don't
know it's weird it's a nightmare this
doesn't make any sense so that was my
last nightmare it's a recurring
nightmare by the way all right we gotta
go we gotta run we gotta run teeth
falling out that means like people don't
want to live or you feel like people
don't listen to you let's get through
the zapper made for this ever okay
here's what it also feels like we're on
a boat my last nightmares I went vegan
hahahahaha
how is that a nightmare I don't know the
Manus it's kind of like it's just a
nightmare man you're just in a it's
scary bro my view botting what's a
viewbot your last nightmare is not
seeing Beth on the stream ah well I hope
that's listening although she's probably
not cuz she's a lot to do oh [ __ ] oh it
[ __ ] burns me
there's a bunch of dead children all
right so maybe I am a vampire if that
light scares me right I'm just trying to
get a reaction because I'm losing now
what does that mean how am i losing I
think I'm doing okay in this game
my name is zombie Pikachu's chasing me
so creepy oh yeah
the scariest nightmare I ever had and
this is a true story was that there were
a bunch of eels chasing me I was in a
lab like an alien 3 not an alien 3 in
Alien Resurrection there's a bunch of
eels chasing me all the eels had
antennas instead of eyes and they had a
giant teeth like underwater fish and
they had bat wings besides their head it
was really [ __ ] scary remove I want
to explore a little bit it's artificial
light Oh get Conan you get Conan what
about that you go up to his office
telling me she come in here he's in some
kind of meeting or something something's
going on up there oh it's look at this
weird room oh this is crazy so is any of
this supposed to make sense I don't get
it weird creepy goo footprints
handprints here's one thing
am I supposed to do something with these
oh I broke it is that good or bad
maybe I should have broken that other
one way back there is that good to break
that hey Zack what's up love it thank
you for not working in for joining us I
jump up on this bed what happens if I
get on this bed nothing all right big
scary eye oh and a dream you're shot in
the head maybe maybe you were in the
matrix dude
I did go on a date with a girl and she
told me she did a bunch of drugs and she
saw herself die a thousand times so
that's interesting
it happens whoa what the [ __ ] ah oh now
I know what you mean by the long arms oh
[ __ ] this
Oh what is this this is great oh that
this is so creepy
there's kids sleeping in the beds this
is fun
this is really creepy all of a sudden
can I leave here yeah great let's get in
the light that's a good idea you know
what I like to do when running from
things get into a big pool of light
see you later long arm freak your boss
may or may not have just heard that it's
Michael Jackson run what does that mean
to Michael Jackson have long arms I
don't think he was so uh
oh I see you're making a tush kids joke
you know it's interesting there's this
great uh this is great essay by this guy
John Jeremiah Sullivan you guys should
all read about Michael Jackson and in it
he says he starts by saying uh of you
but uh thanks love you but god damn it
you banned that dude um it starts by
saying you know Michael Jackson it
starts by saying yeah to understand
Michael Jackson yeah we must first
understand
I said try to understand print screws oh
we're hungry we're so hungry because
we're a vampire and it says print screws
was a sharecropper who you know worked
and got his family out of debt way back
in the day and print screws was like the
great-great great-grandfather of Michael
Jackson and Michael Jackson named his
child Prince after Prince screws but
everybody thought the Michael Jackson
named his kid Prince because he was the
King of Pop so it says if we're wrong
about that what else are we wrong about
with Michael Jackson and it doesn't go
on to say anything definitive about him
but it just kind of makes the point that
the media people jump to conclusions
without truly trying to understand
things oh yeah hunger
so it's a great essay you should all
read it and also what a lazy Michael
Jackson joke come on dude what are you
doing got to be smart
wooof great what an upbeat game there's
a noose that's right I love to Rove
bottig are I see different side you in
these livestream so sassy and confident
like it at all I preferred it when you
were Conan's geeky sidekick thanks I
appreciate it it's weird that I'd be a
human being and have more than one side
to me isn't that strange you guys am I
supposed to do something in here this
kids afraid of the shower I think it's
my favorite game oh man blend
I'm obsessed right now that the witness
is great I've been playing this which is
really fun um my favorite game I love
braid inside was probably my favorite
game of the last five years you know I
like a good Skyrim I like a good fallout
but I'm a fan of like weird indie I'm
here's what I'm a fan of in games stuff
I've never seen before I really like
seems like there's a shadow coming over
here which is bad so I like stuff when
I'm never when I've never seen it before
you just finished inside yesterday how
transistor radio how crazy is that game
so fun so so fun it's interesting I met
the dude one of the guy like the head
programmer for that game at the Game
Awards last year they sat down alpha me
I was like I just have to say I loved
inside wherever he's like oh no I think
I'm sure you wished you thought I'm sure
you wished it was longer and I was like
oh I was like no I thought it was great
he said oh really I was like yeah
so it's interesting how even somebody
who makes something as amazing as inside
still thinks like they could do better
don't jump off there you dumbass am i
jumping over here is that we're doing
you finished inside one minute ago way
to go corporal douche what I think about
shado the classes
John I've never played shadow the
Colossus but I hear awesome things about
it
and I'm dead and we're dead
I wish they would remaster it a shot of
the classes I'd have to what is that
that's PST right I think I'd have to go
back
[Music]
does this room have anything to do with
us who's played this game has anybody
played this game cin on ps3 set Jordan
free trust me Jordan we've tried to set
him free we're like get you get you get
but he won't leave there's an HD version
for ps3 oh cool thanks Mel and cheese
I'll check it out that does kind of suck
I will say like things like half-life 2
and these games that are really awesome
it's hard to go back and play them
because of graphics we're just so
spoiled so it's like unless there's kind
of a remaster version it really stinks
games kind of have kind of a they can
have a shelf life at some point
unlike music or other art forms you know
I got painting you know it doesn't
matter if a painting isn't in HD you
know but a game is an art form is tough
- it's tough to enjoy it as much as you
enjoyed it the first time if I want to
kind of drag this thing or something or
push it I want to get on top of it
do we all agree I have to jump to this
thing or by making that up
the character Oh Alex
great call this character does look like
Georgi shadow the class is one of the
most underrated games ever oh yeah
that's an awesome
yeah I agree transistor yeah inside was
really fun all right I'm just gonna try
it we go now where do I go can I climb
up this oh cool all right here we go
I love in games like characters let's
don't get tired like this would be
exhausting to do this I'd have to take a
nap every news
a livre oh [ __ ] did I die oh thank god
what's a secret
Tan Tasos and you're gonna have some
effed up dreams dude but great dreams
yeah yeah II I love like I could climb
up a whole thing and I can't pull this
stupid lever I am gonna try praying when
it comes out here we go oh come back
come back come back come back just push
the did low to the left some games hold
up due to great art direction yes I
agree with that
nailed it nailed it field goal where's
Conan I want to see Conan you can see
him tonight on TV s at 11:10 central ah
slurred art yes this is the little big
pen people I believe um and it's great I
mean this game is gorgeous do I have to
do something in this room we still think
All Right see you selfie em thank you I
agree this is worth your education
highly agreed sorry anything over here
that I should be driving can I move this
thing nope
I was coding doing now Conan right now
is in this segment meeting so he's
talking to segment producers about the
guests who were on the show today and
those guests are Kurt Russell who's
awesome my favorite people of all time
so I'm gonna have to sneak down and
stare at his face creepily um what's on
the show today
a band uh what are they called something
Batman chick Chicano Batman musical
guest of the show today
and our second guesses who oh and Ron
Funches Ron Funches is amazing he's
coming by today if we did a really fun
stream Cocos Ron Funches at Comic Con
last year hopefully we'll get to do
another one with them again this year
when's the nice close gamer ah great
question um the next game I'm gonna play
tomorrow start working on that tomorrow
I'm not sure when we're gonna shoot it
next but uh writing begins tomorrow
my favorite Carosa movie ooh great
question I mean the thing is maybe my
favorite horror movie of all time so I
gotta go thing things amazing uh you
know I thought death Proof was great uh
man I don't know they're all great dude
big trouble little China's amazing he's
the man even overboard he's great in
even soldier he was great
come on dude am i doing that wrong play
for honor oh I will in a future stream
hey thanks jr. hello UK big trouble chat
is amazing Garnier Fructis first of all
I love your hair conditioner so sleek
and shiny and smells like fruit B uh
what was the question
yes I'm hyper alien covenant I don't
watch more than the trail the teaser
trailer dudes I don't play that game you
have my money stop [ __ ] showing me
[ __ ] that I'm gonna go and pay money for
like what the [ __ ] I hate that am i
doing this wrong or doing this right
well can i play flesh coolest gamer I
can't tell you but it is gonna be a
different one than you would expect
which is gonna be fun I'm very excited
it's gonna be a little bit different
than you'd normally expect do I've steam
yes I do Keegan love me some steam and I
love steam baths but I don't like being
naked I shower with all my clothes on
because then I also wash my clothes at
the same time really it's double duty I
don't have time to wash my clothes and
take a shower our dark oh no this is
from the people who did LittleBigPlanet
and I'm just going to keep going up and
see what happens um the people who did
limbo did the game inside which is also
great oh I see I think I'm supposed to
go up
how do we think we do this
yeah terminator do it hey and said oh
love to Bangladesh there we go
English is great push the little
refrigerator and don't climb the chain
what do you mean
imagine if you play push the little
refrigerator and don't climb the chain I
don't know that that works this feels
like I was going the right way
no I being crazy alright I'm gonna try
this if you [ __ ] me I'm not listening to
the chat anymore you [ __ ] me that's
what happened you [ __ ] me I was doing
it right the first time thank you Bob
god dammit what do I ever look at the
YouTube chat you guys procrastination
Israel all the games are the same oh yes
I don't think so I'm just like a noose
just hanging a lien isolation is so fun
I'm almost done with it I'm probably
going to beat it on Sunday try to help
Thank You Laura
swing the chain
Oh swing it you mean swing it with the
with the let with the lever the leaver
Jordan is needed uh Michelle I'm not
sure marshal Michelle I'm not sure if
this is scary yet it's definitely creepy
inside was legitimately scary there are
moments in that game especially we were
in the water where I was like whoa like
picking up my feet it was like
legitimately freaky it scared the [ __ ]
out of me so did Resident Evil 7 both
very scary can I got a shout-out sure VR
loud gaming let's give her more like
backseat gamer well played
look sometimes conan needs help
something by sometimes I mean all the
time [ __ ] you oh my god well guys the
next hours gonna be me playing this one
part it's gonna be the worst whatever do
you whatever you do don't listen to it
sarin I'm trying not to get flash on
clueless gamer flash who's flash the
pain is real bro this Conan Conan does
like video games perfect so happy this
is great I never saw the first guardians
of the galaxy unfortunately
I think girls will be in Granite's I
think it's awesome I love Kurt Russell
it's great I was fine when he was in sky
high ah black boy
yes that's five lakh blow telltale Costa
Rica loves thank you we're gonna keep
the horror pattern going I don't know
what should we play uh I don't know
maybe outlast - maybe I mean can i play
on a console because I [ __ ] suck on
Pete I suck on PC man just no good
Guardian is one of the best sci-fi films
ever made
whoa high praise check it out yeah
Esteban Nunez I played inside it's
really really fun
it's a great game one of my favorites
Snake Plissken Baby Love Kurt Russell
I'm a huge fan there we go
all right up the thing here we go I need
to play some Starcraft oh I played
Starcraft when I was a kid and it's just
too addictive man it's like you can't
smoke half a crack rock you know you
can't just dabble in Starcraft
I thought Inception did a great oh don't
do that don't do that
I thought Inception did a great job at
making it feel like you were in a dream
I thought that was really cool like how
the walls close in and stuff but my
personal feeling on inception is it is
it was all a dream I don't think we ever
saw real life I think all things a dream
they shot interestingly enough Nolan one
of Christopher Nolan's favorite stages
to use is the stage right next to stage
16 and if you look at the if you look at
the Warner Brothers logo that when it
starts all the buildings that's stage 16
and we're right next to it so you can
actually see our offices in our studio
on every Warner Brothers logo which is
cool but that's where he did the
autonomous swing the chained whoever
said that was smart
[Music]
and yeah he did the revolving elevator
fight an inception next door in stage 16
he also did Dunkirk the end of Dunkirk
next door so what do we think here
there we go got it
I'm definitely a GoSee Dunkirk Dunkirk
Dunkirk
it was weird they called it bodega bay
when it was on the lot that was like the
secret name for it was bodega bay
it's kind of cool I thought huh
can I just get on top of this thing or
is going to make me [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] I'm in a really dark room sorry
we're trying to make it creepy this is
the best we can do
bye Ron I don't know maybe I could see
the chat questions before you see them
or maybe I just know what you're
thinking think about that dudes the
Bodega Bay thing you could see on Google
by the way so don't think I gave you any
great information and that was awesome
I'm terrible at PC gaming y'all can I
convince Conan to start doing all
clueless gamers of the used to have all
his loves I'm set I've tried but he
doesn't he doesn't he likes to celebs
but we had fun
good fun in the VR thing
oh sweet super creepy
oh there's one of those things in the
thing I guess I'll let him out right
does those things help me are they
screwing with me
he's a steam controller yeah you're
right I should the steam controllers are
pretty cool let's push this this is a
bad idea right here comes something
terrible
ah-ha great it's over here
I supposed to grab that thing and then
go all the way back down I've never seen
any VR porn now I also suck at console
gaming yes all right I'll ask about the
starcraft remaster that's what people
want to see this can't be good
right whatever's about to happen can't
be good
[Music]
what's happening now and oh oh wait
we're right back here the hell oh [ __ ]
all we did was turn on the leeches come
on man well get it oh I see
oh we turned this thing off god I got so
we actually did do something good uh
disconcerning mother
this is terrible oh I love you so like
slides into home base
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead Oh turn to
ash it leaches do you suck how often I
eat Porto's never I can't eat that [ __ ]
at Porto's come on man it's delicious
but I can't eat it this game will be way
better in VR I don't think you do this
in VR though it's definitely an eye
I have played PT we played it on this
stream it's really fun
ah Dark Souls is very hard I'm not into
games that are just super hard to just
be hard but I appreciate a good Dark
Souls
I appreciate why people like it and the
challenge it poses let's go ooh I love
it I love this huge oh [ __ ] this sucks
I love I love the uh-oh that's crazy the
sense of scale on this game is very cool
let's go kids I didn't want to know
what's in that big room oh here we go
woo hey first level done this is pretty
similar to limbo and inside I thought
inside was amazing limbo is way too
short and kind of the end was a big
letdown I get caught up in the Ashley
Madison hack Ashley Madison is four is
asking Madison for people who are
married who want to cheat I'm single so
what's the point of me being on Ashley
Madison I can't buy a date so no I was
not caught in that because I was not on
Ashley Madison Ashley Madison is for
people who have the problem of having
too many lovers it's like god I have so
many people who just want to want to go
out with me want to make sweet love to
me I don't have that problem so no I
wasn't on Ashley Madison hey mom's jeans
what happened to the girl at the gym you
don't want to know what half of the girl
of the gym this is creepy
ah some light burns me and some light
doesn't what's up with that just tip
over that lamp to start a fire no big
deal what's it here
oh whoa you can see into the other room
what's happening I can't really see
what's happening damn I do stream on
Twitch we're steering we're streaming on
Twitch right now basel stream usually on
sunday nights on twitch.tv slash aaron
blair narnia hey Keith dapper combo
what's up your trolls are not amazing in
this game I'll say that you're grabbing
something by
all right let's keep going up shut up
Mac furka hey we're in Africa anyways
what's up it's your boy too light bulbs
don't kill vampires
fair enough webbot Oh fair enough you
know what you know what uh
passive-aggressive comments kill
vampires
whoa kids hey it's my bed remember that
well I love look at how stretchy and
crazy this is the art direction this
game is a phenomenal all right I sense a
puzzle coming on kids
I can't link anything cos best on here
I'm sorry dentist are this part is cool
this part is already cool hey Dubai hey
Brazil hey Cape Town I was in Dubai four
times in ten days when we went to
Armenia and Qatar back a couple years
ago it's pretty wild it's a lot of plane
rides over there back
hey I'm Murphy bed with some a piece of
bacon in it this is like a hot pocket
what's up I think that's like a piece of
like cooked bacon or something
it's pretty weird uh I want to go here
up here
whoa weird I'm in the sink with a sink
hey Zacharias we decided to start
streaming on Wednesdays instead of
Mondays because it was kind of was a lot
I liked that rug - look the rug isn't
high that's dope
uh it was a lot to start the week off
and new games come out tuesdays that way
we can play them the next day now we
already did this you gotta get up here
John Smith Sharansky is actually doing
work I know it's hard to believe but he
came in here the other day and we had a
fun time perfect dead
awesome killed it but he can't come in
every week I'm sorry hey Kosovo next
time is gonna be reviewing that Conan I
don't know we'll see I don't know if
everything's China we're just tiny but
doesn't matter I'm gonna say
everything's giant because there are
other tiny things ah maybe not though
was my diet when I lost so much weight
lean meats and vegetables no beer
alcohol no cheese it wasn't great it's
very nothing fun to eat very low carb I
played persona 5 no I have it how is it
should I play persona 5 it's insane
right but people really like it
that's right we did a close game with
PewDiePie's it was extremely nice hey
serbia what's up i playing the
dishonored games ah I have not dishonor
- looks awesome though there's a glitch
little glitchy glitch sorry I got a
don't wake the sleeping bacon I've
always said that you guys have known
I've said that for years I see we didn't
hit that key on the table
key on the table baby there's still
stream restrictions on what game I'm
just honored no manhunt - that game with
all the dicks perfect this kid is going
to have really bad knees what I do this
key
there you go
I like how you just throw stuff just a
little bit in this game but in the whole
look doesn't this game feel like like a
claymation or something it's so cool
gyro light novel game what's gyro light
Oh persona has limitations push that
door nice and wide open something creepy
that's horrifying
huh
let me do here we got throw this thing
up at the button there we go
did Jordan actually work there Oh some
random uh now he's worked these were the
chefs in slot along on half he's the
reason why I went on the first wets mr.
dog remote the last I'm sorry the last
ones mr. dog remote with triumph what do
we do here kids what do we do here
interesting
I got to carry the dumb monkey thing
what's sleeping dogs all right later
jungle Germania thanks for joining us
oh [ __ ] I plant amnesia machine for pigs
I have it was fun
yeah the movie you're thinking of the
monkey toy Nina briea's is monkeyshines
scary best game ever played The Last of
Us I agree Jack Porter that games insane
so fun so so so fun can't wait for the
second one I might go see King Arthur I
like Charlie huh no in Jude Law
do the monkey oh I'm dying kids so
hungry
what's happening here was this the rat
chases me
oh no sequel to what is not going to
come up
Jordans in his office doing work Final
Fantasy 11 gonna play that stuff I don't
get it what's happening here
can I eat the monkey what's going on
it's goddamn rats out of here
why does this feel like a trap eat the
meat
dude we are a vampire right are we a
vampire I'm gonna get caught in here I
totally moving a con here yep nothing
else to be done though what else am I
supposed to do I had to do it kids I had
to do it to put the story forward oh
this is oh look at this dude whoo I love
it tonight now it's getting fun oh I see
guys I'll I'll look at outlast - okay
you don't need to keep saying it over
and over I swear I'll look at it
ah the old knocked the thing over trick
I didn't feel like I if I ever got
kidnapped I'd be in good shape because
my video game knowledge you know how to
escape stuff
I feel like video games are all training
it training us all for the zombie
apocalypse what the [ __ ] am I supposed
to do here seems impossible we're going
to go back over this way the creepy
long-arm guy scariest game I've ever
played was Resident Evil 7 in the VR
that was so scary horrified
I see Skull Island No
sometimes yeah I mean outlast was scary
yeah but like kind of like it was like
oh you have a crazy doctor who you know
it's like some of that stuff is scary I
don't know like alien isolation was
freaky is freaky um but if it gets too
like insane like oh there's a guy who
doesn't have skin on his fit you know
it's kind of like all right I get it I
mean the other thing that makes outlast
that makes alien isolation scary is it's
not I mean I know it's fantastical but
it's not super crazy you know what I'm
saying a it's hard to explain
just like in horror movies I don't get
super freaked out of it there's not some
semblance of reality in there can I what
is happening here
yeah I can't tell either Slee -
something - that's the hard thing the
depth thing is tough because I should
look side to side I can't really tell
how far away that is I agree with you is
it closer to me or further away okay
it's behind me I can tell from the floor
maybe
also the doing the trigger to grab stuff
is it's tough man it kind of sucks ice a
new streaming site beam I have not
it's hard to tell I can't really tell
where it is
maybe is it supposed to be underneath
that splotch by the way I don't care
about like releasing these kids that
seems like a little shitty I should
release this kid huh you can't
that's awful there it is yeah that's
hard it depth is tough in this game man
that's a tough thing [ __ ] you if you're
going to make the illusion of depth make
it a strong choice you know okay let's
grab another thing and pull it over
right kids capital this one over nope
how is this going to work
lunch day I'll try beam then it's a
design trick pull it more you got to
swing on it
Oh swing on it the jump off yeah there
we go YouTube chat helping us out
YouTube chat all is forgiven
I have pleaded evil within I wasn't a
huge fan I yes I beat a limbo Excalibur
as fun but it was fun but a little that
ending was super disappointing this is a
little bit like limbo zombies are Call
of Duty Conan is terrible at games guys
wait what happened here
oh did I get smooshed by the door
favorite game of all time that's a great
question
I like we tennis a lot Red Dead
Redemption is amazing
kids got have so many bruises yeah I got
I got I done got smooshed but now you
know what no ways to work we found out
how far away the hanger thing is h1z1 is
fun I played that on my own channel I
couldn't find anybody ran around it was
the [ __ ] best that's just terrible
top 10 games of all time damn son a lot
of other games killcount these music I
think we're up to like six right now I'm
playing the witness I'm playing this I'm
playing alien isolation they're all
great through the door maybe also start
saying bay bay a lot which is just I'm
the worst person ever you can't keep
saying baby okay
Oh
I did play csgo I played it acts with
Dan G slang for charity Dingley singing
I you know him as the amazing guy from
Big Brother super cool hopefully we'll
have them on here one day and I got my
ass kicked and also he he [ __ ] up the
chat we were playing every play and I
was so bad he kind of [ __ ] up and said
he was like hey help him out or whatever
but I heard him say it which is really
nice of him um but I definitely I
definitely he had other people helping
me out so don't talk shoot of so much
and I was like oh god I felt very bad oh
maybe you can't see Kenya
so just try to run past this guy let's
do it
we can't come over here I guess I'm
[ __ ] I think you go long arms is even
more horrifying when you see all of them
the thing is I'm just never gonna be
good enough at first-person shooters to
really give it a good shot so I'd like
to play by myself of those things I'm
just gonna run my [ __ ] this guy right
later sucker I'm out of here
eat [ __ ] oh no oh wait no I'm [ __ ] oh
no ah ah damn it
protip don't run into a dead end when
you're running from somebody what's my
top 17 games that start anthropomorphize
bottles I name one I don't even know one
that has a bottle is imperson bottle man
slide through the hole that's what she
said about this game and what I'm about
to do boom
oops didn't really slide whoa miss oh
come on oh come on you dick what's this
what's this yeah
what I was pressing the Run button what
does he do dizzy eat me or something why
does he have any any eyes the style of
this games reminds you've caught Amara
Demasi I don't think so about a whole
bottom right alright there we go
so she said all right I got to stop
doing that here we go here we go he's
got a weird like flesh thing over his
face slide oh damn it I slid right to
the wad go underneath the day go
underneath the thing dude go Jesus cool
so I'm about to die it's what's about to
happen I see so I gotta get the thing
and do the crank to do the thing this is
going to suck so hard dude can I be
sneaky sneaky but he smells you though
right
ten bucks says he's gonna come back when
I start doing this come on
come on man I don't know goddamn day I
knew it
[ __ ] you I'm out of here [ __ ] whoa
later sucker here come his long arms
I wish as long I'm sure you come down
there there we go ah Jesus Christ that's
a bad idea
shocked he didn't try to reach down and
grab me shocked
oh this is this room must smell terrible
this room must smell so much like feet
this is I don't want to be down here at
all yep I knew that was gonna happen we
all do that what's gonna happen
am i safe on the thing they found a
thing now great this monster is a guy
love smelling feet oh I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I don't know why there's so many
shoes guys but there's a it's gotta be a
this is like tremors but with shoes yeah
that's like the trash compactor in
Monster new hope except with a pervert
who like smelling feet all right here we
go
I think if I jump I can get a better I'm
saying
climb up on the thing please ald oh [ __ ]
hey be the line we will alright here we
go
use all the briefcase rest points okay
I'm gonna I'm gonna run to it
oh yeah in your face [ __ ] where's the
next one oh my god the next one's way
over there oh I'm definitely gonna get
killed
there's no way dude there's no way I'm
gonna make it all the way over there is
there one down here no way I'm so [ __ ]
you think that's one over there oh
there's no all right well let's try this
no way it's gonna go well oh maybe
gotcha happen later perv I hate noises
and things that are noisy oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
you slid it this guy sucks you suck you
suck you suck you suck you suck you suck
you suck you suck you suck not cool not
cool where we going where we going climb
up the thing oh cool great I'm dead
great I'm dead I'm dead cool so cool so
dead oh Jesus Christ
ah how am I supposed to do here oh my
god dude hey my name is TJ one two three
four I like your name
climb the left door climb the left door
what does that mean oh right right right
okay cool slide keep going let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go you [ __ ]
sneaky or on the side here we go
on the left door what's up with the left
door dude
hide in the box back right I can't get
up that box by the way this guy like
having good a good sense of smell he's
got a tiny nose oh [ __ ] let's go after
the monster is trying to kill us I love
that
[Music]
[ __ ]
he doesn't smell oh he's a good sense of
hearing
ah okay fair enough if your monkey dials
back what do we do with this box
anybody know I'm just pushing it cuz you
can and this game was great
yeah the kids crept out of his pockets
maybe so many things and games are just
like well I can do this I might as well
like kind of get in this box I can't
[Music]
ah [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up dude you're
gonna get us caught Wow this [ __ ]
with a speaker distraction of it oh look
at all these kids this game is starting
to get kind of creepy can I go down here
whoa all right a little bit depth a for
no reason
cool give him a Pepsi already all right
guys I get it Wow everybody's such a
great comedy writer in the feed today
give him a poopsie give him a Pepsi yeah
I guess what I read Twitter - he's like
daredevil you think he's blind but he's
not what exactly do I do here maybe
throw the thing down here then you'll
hear it and then I come back up right is
that the idea
he's still looking for me what's
happening here
give them a fleshlight well that's a
different spin on it he's got to smash
through the floor
BYOB means bring your own baby yeah I
guess I need him did I need him to break
through the floor so I can get out right
that's the whole thing die Aaron die I'm
trying Petru I'm really trying to die
but it's not working
well maybe I crawl up this way there we
go
ah here's an idea
oh [ __ ] you I was so much less loud by
the way also doesn't have big years so I
don't know he's hearing me
yes Lord a coup actually not the punches
didn't hurt but when he kicked me it
actually and actually legitimately hurt
quite a bit
ah the carpet makes you silent
[Music]
[Music]
okay okay there we go
keep climbing baby he's got some long
ass arms holy [ __ ] dude climb up what
are you doing dude nightmares
I like how ugly he is but the Fedora
does doesn't even fit his head that's
true he's got terrible fashion sense
that's what it is my laugh scared the
hell out of you has that effect on most
women oh dope
what is this what's going on here what's
the [ __ ]
his skin slides off his skull that's
what it is Jesus
no way this is gonna go well definitely
gonna hear me in here
[Music]
bro hit the foot how do we hit that
button I'm gonna shoe
I gotta get a shoe Dimmie why would this
guy keep clocks with alarms around if
you sensitive to hearing it doesn't make
any sense
[Music]
I mean I guess it's a dream so it's not
supposed to make sense there has to be
more of them where he's crazy fast for
having such tiny legs
later sucker love for those clocks that
go off
here he comes right he's definitely
coming through here right we all know
that here he comes
this is nuts dead
how does this work huh killing with a
piano yeah let's kill with a piano oh
this will be great we're gonna smush his
dumb stupid-head uh-oh it's like handle
Oh No
we would fall from such a great height
here he comes
you know he's coming kids you know he's
coming so many books falling off oh [ __ ]
come on bro this guy's house is filthy
by the way just want to point that out
it's really gross
you gonna smush his dumb stupid-head
we gonna smush she's dumb head oh we
need to find the old crank Aroo feeling
a bit cranky are we get it when I try
Snickers really satisfies
I like how it's blurry so creepy like
that blurry stuff in the back this is
this game is absolute gorgeous shittiest
librarian ever by the way
I'll get your book in a second sir I
please I reserved this book it's under
Blaire okay just one second
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes action he's gonna come in here isn't
he cuz he's a piece of [ __ ] cuz he sucks
he's definitely coming in here we all
know he's coming in here right otherwise
how do I get out of this room
that's literally me during finals
uh but what if I but can i oh TV right
we turn the teeth let's put this over
here shall we let me slide out the back
turn it on please I turn the TV on or
break the TV
or what would I do
can I just light this whole thing on
fire and kill this stupid idiot oh the
chair kind of we can kind of move it no
we can't it's too heavy
no way pushing this thing is gonna get
me turn the TV on I don't see any porn
to put in the TV guys so everyone is
suggesting that not sure that's gonna
work but thanks Oh yoo-hoo
captain long arms [ __ ] [ __ ]
bull [ __ ]
should should have taken the shortcut
should have taken the shortcut
Oh God
well oh I didn't die I didn't die that
was crazy now I'm in a weird glitchy
area can I jump around dead I'm dead
yeah we're dead well guys I think that's
gonna do it for this stream khoka thank
you all for joining us we played a
little a little nightmare we played a
little little image we played little
neighbors today kind of blast
join me on Sunday stream on twitch.tv
slash Aaron blip but a great time thank
you for joining us make sure to watch
tonight Kurt Russell's on the show
Conan 11th ed central it's Kurt Russell
you got your you got your Ron Funches
he's amazing one of my favorite people
in the world and of course
musical guest Chicano Batman and we will
see you right back here next Wednesday
hopefully playing a little bit of oculus
all right we'll see you guys later bye
you
you
you